well good iron I mean there are many
aspects to her I wish you know we can't
go in detail but um I I do not have the
same reuse as she has I think she's very
militantly anti-islam while I do see
more colors or no answers into it but
one thing that I that I object to in the
attacks on her is that first of all they
cannot accept that a woman can come from
a Muslim background and have the views
that ion has while any society would
meet those views as well it is good to
have someone who is radically and
fundamentally against you in order to
challenge you to interrogate your ideas
to make you think about yourself I mean
if you agree that your democratic you
don't attack iron as something as a
Western entity because she loves Western
liberal ideas and also remember that the
fundamentalists Islamists got their
philosophy from the West only they got
it from the fascists and and the and the
Stalinists it's not as if they are
purely Islamic that traditional Islamic
are not like these people you know so
those who attack iron themselves are
attacking in a western style you know
and and the second thing that but anyway
she's talking experiences female genital
mutilation might be a cultural product
and not just a much islamic product but
the islamic society is not saying that
it's bad so as long as they are not
rejecting it people would say it's
islamic if it's just the culture that
belongs to long time ago why don't you
abolish it you know so there is that
problem that that stays the state is
very good at abolishing a lot of things
you know and the last thing about iron
that is very disturbing is that this
woman for what she has been saying
and let us say that everything that
she's been saying has been terrible you
know but for her words and for her
opinions
she's condemned to to live in hiding
basically because of the fear for her
life
and I think that this is an issue that
we should take seriously in a democratic
society
when we attack her more than we attack
the conditions that put her in that
situation